Shure: 你快找去让他输
Shure: Hurry up and find him to make him lose.
其他人：我们桌面有一种凌乱的美感
Others: Our desk has a kind of messy beauty.
Shure: 嗯他这分辨率就就就会这个样子
Shure: Yeah, this resolution will just be like this.
Shure: 不要瞎说大实话好吗
Shure: Don't go around speaking harsh truths, okay?
Shure: （歌词）they care enough for living
Shure: (Lyrics) they care enough for living
Shure: （歌词）and for me
Shure: (Lyrics) and for me
Shure: （歌词）night keeps spreading light
Shure: (Lyrics) night keeps spreading light
Shure: 这是谁啊
Shure: Who is this?
Shure: 这照片是你吗哈哈哈
Shure: Is this photo of you? Hahaha
其他人：真讨厌
Others: So annoying.
Shure: 是咱闺女是吧哈哈哈
Shure: Is this our daughter? Hahaha
其他人：那是你妹妹好
Others: That's your sister, okay?
其他人：那是你姐姐好
Others: That's your older sister, okay?
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
其他人：我是他妈
Others: I'm his mom.
其他人： 来接孩子放学呢
Others: Here to pick up the kid from school.
其他人：妈有什么东西
Others: Mom, what do you have?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
其他人：妈
Others: Mom.
其他人：干嘛
Others: What are you doing?
Shure: 想拔了真的想拔了
Shure: I really want to pull it out, I really do.
其他人：不能拔
Others: You can't pull it out.
Shure: 拔了真不长
Shure: If you pull it out, it won't grow back.
其他人：不行
Others: No way.
Shure: 我这个长的是意外
Shure: Mine growing was an accident.
Shure: （歌词）there are people dying
Shure: (Lyrics) there are people dying
Shure: （歌词）if you care enough for living
Shure: (Lyrics) if you care enough for living
Shure: we can
其他人：干嘛不要乱动
Others: What are you doing? Don't mess around.
Shure: 第一人称Ra
Shure: First person Ra
Shure: 怎么要要喝什么
Shure: What do you want to drink?
Shure: 他
Shure: He...
其他人：你跟带了尾巴一样
Others: It's like you have a tail.
Shure: 这是我的生命线
Shure: This is my lifeline.
Shure: 揣在兜里怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with putting it in my pocket?
Shure: 这一脸无奈
Shure: This face of helplessness.
其他人：你就痴呆吧你要睡了
Others: You're just dazed, you need to sleep.
Shure: 来杯咖啡吧
Shure: How about a cup of coffee?
Shure: 谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 谢老板来杯咖啡吗
Shure: Jake, would you like a cup of coffee?
Shure: 好谢老板感冒了
Shure: Okay, Jake caught a cold.
其他人：感冒不能喝咖啡吗
Others: Can't you drink coffee when you have a cold?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Shure: 所以他才看着这么累啊
Shure: That's why he looks so tired.
Katrina: 修硕啊你保管吧
Katrina: Shure, you take care of it.
Shure: 我保管了
Shure: I got it.
Katrina: 你不是货币发起人吗
Katrina: Aren't you the currency initiator?
Shure: 这这还有假币是吗
Shure: Are there counterfeit bills?
Katrina: 这这这个也算吧
Katrina: This could be considered one.
Shure: 假币
Shure: Counterfeit money.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
其他人：我先我先偷一个
Others: Let me steal one first.
Shure: 你不能偷
Shure: You can't steal.
Shure: 我们这通货是固定的好吗
Shure: Our currency is fixed, okay?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
其他人：有个充电宝坏了
Others: A power bank is broken.
Shure: you jump i jump
其他人：你真讨厌
Others: You're so annoying.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
其他人：哦不这个这个是这个灯
Others: Oh no, it's this light.
Katrina: 这是吗这好像不是吧
Katrina: Is it? It doesn't seem like it.
Katrina: 这好像不是吧
Katrina: It doesn't seem like it.
Shure: 这是吧
Shure: It is, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 这是这是
Shure: It is, it is.
Katrina: 可以是是哈哈
Katrina: It could be, haha.
其他人：可以是好
Others: It could be, okay.
Shure: 完了开始已经有假币流入市场了
Shure: Great, counterfeit bills have already entered the market.
其他人：你刚刚给我几个
Others: How many did you just give me?
Katrina: 给了你4个好像
Katrina: I gave you 4, I think.
Shure: 这个镜子照人显高你知道吗
Shure: This mirror makes people look taller, you know?
Shure: 看真的
Shure: Look, really.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
其他人：完全完全看不出来
Others: Totally, totally can't tell.
Shure: 不要一脸嫌弃的眼神看着我
Shure: Don't look at me with that disgusted look.
Katrina: 一楼吗对
Katrina: First floor, right?
其他人：我在一楼藏的也都没找到
Others: I hid on the first floor too and couldn't find anything.
其他人：我发现我非常适合藏东西
Others: I found that I'm really good at hiding things.
Shure: 拉链
Shure: Zipper.
其他人：拉着呢
Others: Holding it.
Shure: 没拉似的
Shure: Doesn't seem like it.
其他人：拉着呢 拉着呢
Others: Holding it. Holding it.
其他人：着谁的歌
Others: Whose song is this?
Shure: 二区六楼
Shure: Sixth floor, Section 2.
Shure: 昨天看完你发的推送我就又去听了
Shure: After reading your post yesterday, I listened to it again.
其他人：之前我感觉在济南看过一场
Others: I feel like I've seen a show in Jinan before.
Shure: 而且他们原来没有二区六楼这个名字
Shure: And they didn't originally have the name "Sixth floor, Section 2."
Shure: 他们就叫monage
Shure: They were just called Monage.
其他人：这是你的mac吗
Others: Is this your Mac?
其他人：这是macpro吗
Others: Is this a MacBook Pro?
其他人：我总感觉这个不像pro
Others: I feel like this doesn't look like a Pro.
其他人：这个看起来
Others: This looks...
其他人：如果我想把之前我电脑里的
Others: If I want to transfer the files from my previous computer...
Jake: 来我要jump 你了
Jake: Hey, I need to jump you.
Shure: 哎jump我吧
Shure: Hey, jump me.
Jake: 哎等一下我可能还要加两个
Jake: Wait a second, I might need to add two more.
Shure: 我叫修硕的
Shure: My name is Shure.
Shure: MacBook Pro是吗
Shure: Is this a MacBook Pro?
其他人：你那个10分钟应该到了吧你再开一下
Others: Your 10 minutes should be up, restart it.
Shure: 还是sorry
Shure: Still, sorry.
Shure: 它这个不分
Shure: It doesn't differentiate.
Shure: 那个 10分钟
Shure: That 10 minutes.
Katrina: 看见空调遥控器了吗
Katrina: Have you seen the AC remote?
Shure: 没有我很热
Shure: No, I'm really hot.
Katrina: 那在谁房间里
Katrina: Then whose room is it in?
Shure: i'm so hot
Shure: I'm so hot.
Shure: 你笑什么
Shure: Why are you laughing?
Katrina: 这个词用起来他是有歧义的
Katrina: That phrase has a double meaning.
Shure: 我知道
Shure: I know.
Shure: 每天就在这挖双关梗
Shure: Every day just digging for double entendres.
其他人：我操这个cash我想怎么给他导出来
Others: Damn, how do I export this cache?
其他人：坏了还不一样
Others: It's broken, isn't it the same?
Shure: 我那个cash是那个cash for Windows
Shure: My cache is for Windows.
其他人：有办法能导出来吗
Others: Is there a way to export it?
Shure: 什么呀
Shure: What?
Shure: 可以点那个Edit
Shure: You can click on Edit.
其他人：啊他可能要loading一下
Others: Ah, it might need to load.
Shure: profice
Shure: Profice.
Shure:  然后哪个是你
Shure: Then which one is yours?
Shure: 这个现在是这个邮件
Shure: This is the email now.
其他人：edit
Others: Edit
Shure: 哎不是这个右键
Shure: Oh no, it's not the right-click.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 也不是roots
Shure: It's not roots either.
Shure: 是哪来着settings
Shure: Where was it... settings.
Shure: 对对这是URL
Shure: Yes, yes, this is the URL.
Shure: 然后复制粘贴过去就可以
Shure: Then just copy and paste it over.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 什么消息
Shure: What message?
Shure: 啊没事
Shure: Ah, it's nothing.
Shure: 还有那个
Shure: And also...
Katrina: 那个他好像在弹你的吉他
Katrina: It looks like he's playing your guitar.
Katrina: 可以吗
Katrina: Is that okay?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Katrina: 他可以弹你的吉他吗
Katrina: Can he play your guitar?
Shure: 他可以他可以
Shure: He can, he can.
Katrina: OK他在弹你的吉他
Katrina: Okay, he's playing your guitar.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 我刚才拿拿出一瓶苏打水
Shure: I just took out a bottle of soda water.
Shure: 哈 3:15我们
Shure: Ha, at 3:15 we...
Jake:哦人齐了吗
Jake: Oh, is everyone here?
Shure: 我刚才拿瓶苏打水放那
Shure: I just put the bottle of soda water there.
Katrina: 但是人没齐是不是
Katrina: But not everyone is here, right?
Jake: 差谁点一下吧
Jake: Who's missing? Let's check.
Katrina: 呃LUCIA的朋友来了吗没来吧
Katrina: Uh, did Lucia's friend come? No, right?
Jake: 点一下 每个人看看
Jake: Check, let's see everyone.
Jake: Lucia Lucia在哪
Jake: Lucia, where is Lucia?
Katrina: 路夏在一楼烧那个东西
Katrina: Lucia is on the first floor burning something.
Katrina: 我要拿个奶酪包
Katrina: I need to get a cheese bun.
Jake: 我问问去
Jake: I'll go ask.
Jake: 你去接
Jake: You go pick it up.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina: 我刚刚接
Katrina: I just picked it up.
Katrina: 找了半天我天哪
Katrina: I looked for it for a long time, geez.
Katrina: 天太随意了我们
Katrina: We're so casual.
Shure: 度假来了
Shure: It's like we're on vacation.
Shure: 这谁的
Shure: Whose is this?
Shure: 接受
Shure: Accept.
Shure: 储存到下载
Shure: Save to downloads.
Shure: 储存到下载就行
Shure: Just save it to downloads.
其他人：还有PPT吗
Others: Do we still have the PPT?
Shure: yes咱们第一天不是PPT吗
Shure: Yes, didn't we use the PPT on the first day?
Jake: 对是PPT
Jake: Yeah, it was a PPT.
Katrina: 第一项不是你去答题吗
Katrina: Wasn't the first task to answer questions?
Shure: PPT不就INTRDATION吗
Shure: Isn't the PPT just the introduction?
Katrina: 我以为你INTRDATION
Katrina: I thought you were doing the introduction.
Katrina: 是他们INTRDATION呢
Katrina: Or were they doing the introduction?
Shure: 啊不是不
Shure: No, no, it's not like that.
Katrina: 最后一个
Katrina: The last one.
Shure: 啊刚才拿完放这了
Shure: I just placed it here.
Jake: 摆摆摆摆  摆一排
Jake: Line them up.
其他人：来开摆
Others: Let's get them lined up.
Jake: 摆摆摆快摆
Jake: Line them up quickly.
Jake: 别他妈坐着
Jake: Don't just sit there.
Katrina: 那我们垫垫子坐地上行吗
Katrina: Can we sit on the floor with cushions?
其他人：可以这样坐在地上
Others: Yeah, we can sit on the floor like that.
Katrina: 第一天还是比较拘谨的
Katrina: The first day, we were kind of reserved.
Katrina: 所以我坐了凳子
Katrina: So I sat on a chair.
其他人：你可以一会选择坐在地上刚好两个靠背
Others: You can choose to sit on the floor later, with two backrests.
Shure: 咱们
Shure: We...
Katrina: 今天就无所谓了
Katrina: Today it doesn't matter.
Shure: 有道理
Shure: Makes sense.
Katrina: 几个嘉宾
Katrina: How many guests?
Katrina: 好像是6个人
Katrina: Seems like six people.
Shure: 老嫌弃我干什么
Shure: Why do you keep disliking me?
其他人：我没有啊
Others: I'm not.
Shure: 没有吗没有吗
Shure: Really? Really?
其他人：我没有啊
Others: I'm not.
Shure: 那你是在
Shure: Then what are you...
Katrina: 唉我冰淇淋呢
Katrina: Hey, where's my ice cream?
Shure: 往后摆前排摆一摆
Shure: Move it back, line it up in the front row.
Shure: 一排这
Shure: One row here.
Shure: 给我给我留一个
Shure: Save one for me.
Shure: 我在这放PPT的
Shure: I’m setting up the PPT here.
Shure: 那我站着也行
Shure: I can stand too.
其他人：前排是VIP观众席
Others: The front row is for VIP seats.
Shure: yes
Shure: Yes.
其他人：一会把刘帅新买的mac给砸了
Others: Later, we might smash Choiszt's new Mac.
Shure: 没事 7天好像又无理由换
Shure: It's fine, I think there's a 7-day return policy.
其他人：那我岂不可以第七天把我mac摔了
Others: So, can I just smash my Mac on the seventh day?
其他人：管你跳我好
Others: Whatever, do what you want.
其他人：讨厌你几天了你还在那个界面上
Others: I've hated you for days, and you're still on that screen.
Shure: 关了关了关
Shure: Turn it off, turn it off.
Shure: 不会的不会的
Shure: No, it won't happen.
Shure: 请
Shure: Please.
其他人：所以我需要下去吗
Others: So, do I need to go down?
Shure: 应该我们现在需要下去吗
Shure: Should we go down now?
Shure: 叉叉
Shure: Jack.
Shure: 我们需要下去吗
Shure: Do we need to go down?
其他人：应该不用吧一会他们上来
Others: Probably not, they'll come up later.
其他人：把线拔掉我不需要了
Others: Unplug the cable, I don't need it anymore.
其他人：哦直接放这就可以
Others: Oh, just leave it here.
Shure: 干嘛下去
Shure: Why go down?
Shure: 哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Shure: 哈哈仿佛知道我下句要说什么一样
Shure: Haha, it's like you knew what I was about to say.
其他人：什么你要说什么
Others: What were you about to say?
Shure: 我说你怎么开始合群了哈哈哈
Shure: I was gonna say, how come you're starting to fit in now, haha.
其他人：很惊讶吗
Others: Are you surprised?
其他人：这现在凳子一会也可以搬上去
Others: This chair can be moved upstairs later.
其他人：那感觉放不下
Others: It might not fit.
Shure: （歌词）我到底做了什么
Shure: (lyrics) What did I do?
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 这小马可以搬上去吗
Jake: Can this little horse be moved upstairs?
Shure: 也可以vvvip
Shure: Yeah, it can be vvvip.
其他人：那我来骑马
Others: Then I'll ride the horse.
Jake: 好那就算了
Jake: Okay, never mind.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Jake: 太重了是吧
Jake: Is it too heavy?
Shure: 你就是nice
Shure: You're just nice.
Jake: 牛批哎呀
Jake: Awesome, oh man.
Shure: EGO Knight好吧
Shure: EGO Knight, okay.
其他人：他是Ego house
Others: He's EGO house.
Shure: 他是EGO house
Shure: He's EGO house.
Shure: 你是IGO Knight
Shure: You're IGO Knight.
其他人：歧视
Others: Discrimination.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Shure: 哇你们俩
Shure: Wow, you two.
其他人：我觉得这虾球
Others: I think this shrimp ball.
Shure: 这这这还
Shure: This, this, this still.
其他人： 都吃不起
Others: Can't afford it
Shure: 来来给你给你俩照一张
Shure: Come on, let me take a picture of you two
Shure: 你干什么
Shure: What are you doing
Shure: 不是你你是骑士
Shure: No, you're a knight
Shure: 戴耳钉会怎么样吗
Shure: What's the deal with wearing earrings
其他人：我戴的是耳钉吗
Others: Am I wearing earrings
其他人：别他妈自我代入
Others: Don't impose yourself on it
Shure: 你戴的是摇滚是吗哈哈
Shure: You're wearing rock style, right, haha
Alice: 我要整个形
Alice: I want a shape
Alice: 爱心
Alice: A heart
其他人：恶心啊
Others: Gross
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up
其他人：没有我现在看你我就想笑
Others: Nothing, I just feel like laughing when I see you now
Shure: 怎么太多天看不着
Shure: Haven't seen me for too long
Shure: 没乐子看了是吗
Shure: No fun without me, right
其他人：应该把杜导喊来
Others: We should call Director Du
Shure: 把杜老喊来干嘛
Shure: What's the point of calling Old Du
Lucia: 啊我小伙伴说他到花庄地铁站了
Lucia: Ah, my friend said he is at Huazhuang Station
Alice: 公主你他妈赶紧去吃啊
Alice: Princess, you better go eat
Shure: 不就是回去见家长吗
Shure: Aren't you just going back to meet the parents
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 公主请吃
Alice: Princess, please eat
Alice: 这是耻辱
Alice: This is a disgrace
其他人：喊啥呢喊姐妹
Others: What are you shouting, shout for your sister
Alice: 萱哈哈哈哈
Alice: Xuan, hahaha
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
其他人：喊妹妹吧
Others: Just call her sister
Shure: 你非得要当一把大爷是吗
Shure: Do you really have to act like a big boss
其他人：嫂子
Others: Sister-in-law
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What the heck
Shure: 嫂子开门
Shure: Sister-in-law, open the door
Shure: 我是我哥是吧
Shure: I'm your brother, right
Alice: 就一点点
Alice: Just a little bit
Tasha: 好了刚好
Tasha: Alright, just right
Shure: 我们给他加油
Shure: Let's cheer him on
其他人：哪都贴那个小眼睛
Others: Stick those little eyes everywhere
其他人：怎么已经吸不出来水了呢
Others: Why can't you suck out any more water
Alice: 是不是水太少了
Alice: Is there too little water
Lucia: 看起来还有半瓶点
Lucia: Looks like there's still half a bottle left
Alice: 你点他不管用哦
Alice: Clicking it won't work.
Alice: 那个啥他没插电吗不是
Alice: Is it not plugged in?
Shure: 到你
Shure: Your turn.
Tasha: 没插电
Tasha: It's not plugged in.
Alice: 你看那个那个那个那个
Alice: Look at that, that, that...
其他人：哦他现在在用是吧
Others: Oh, he's using it now, right?
Alice: 呃哪个不用啊
Alice: Uh, which one isn't being used?
Tasha: 微波炉不用了拔掉吧
Tasha: The microwave isn't being used, unplug it.
Alice: 这个好像不用
Alice: This one isn't being used.
Alice: 这个你别拔错了这个烤鸭正在烤
Alice: Don't unplug the wrong one, the roast duck is cooking.
Shure: 看我干嘛看
Shure: Why are you looking at me?
其他人：你看我干嘛看
Others: Why are you looking at me?
Shure: 你好看哈哈哈
Shure: Because you look good, haha.
Alice: 要不你去其他地方把它挪走
Alice: Maybe move it to another place.
其他人：二楼是不是还有水
Others: Is there water on the second floor?
Tasha: 二楼那个是正常的
Tasha: The one on the second floor is fine.
Alice: 二楼也有
Alice: There's one on the second floor too.
Shure: 今天有多少个人
Shure: How many people are here today?
Shure: 我算一算
Shure: Let me count.
Shure: 咱们都开始说9-11个人是吗
Shure: We're all saying there are 9-11 people, right?
Shure: 还是9-13个人对啊
Shure: Or is it 9-13 people, yeah?
Katrina: 你说所有吗
Katrina: You mean everyone?
Lucia: 可以用这个纸
Lucia: You can use this paper.
Katrina: 不止不止
Katrina: Not just that, not just that.
Katrina: 我们都有 10个人
Katrina: We have 10 people.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Katrina: 加6个嘉宾吧差不多
Katrina: Plus 6 guests, roughly.
Lucia: 呃是到哪里啊
Lucia: Uh, where is it?
Lucia: 跟他说一下
Lucia: Let him know.
其他人：到时光旅人5号院
Others: To the Time Traveler's Courtyard No. 5.
Katrina: 呃我的打孔器呢
Katrina: Uh, where's my hole puncher?
Katrina: 又找不到
Katrina: Can't find it again.
Shure: 在外面呢
Shure: It's outside.
Shure: 你打红心
Shure: You aim for the bullseye.
Katrina: 刚外面没看见呀
Katrina: I didn't see it outside just now.
其他人：对你说打车吧
Others: Yeah, call a cab.
其他人：因为走路的话走两公里还是太远了
Others: Walking two kilometers is too far.
Shure: 咱早上不在外面呢看着呢
Shure: Weren't we outside this morning watching?
Katrina: 打打孔器哈哈哈
Katrina: Hole puncher, haha.
Jake: 剪映
Jake: Cutscene.
其他人：你怎么了
Other: What's wrong with you?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
其他人：没想到我真应是吧
Other: Didn't expect me to actually answer, huh?
Shure: 好好不害臊就行
Shure: It's fine, just don't be shy.
其他人：怎么了乖儿子
Other: What's wrong, my dear son?
其他人：接你放学是吧
Other: Picking you up from school, right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 我在幼儿园表现可好了
Shure: I behaved really well in kindergarten.
Shure: 完了我的我的
Shure: Oh no, my... my...
Shure: 以为找到了
Shure: Thought I found it.
Shure: 我昨天藏这了
Shure: I hid it here yesterday.
Shure: 不要不干什么
Shure: Don't... don't do anything.
Shure: 你怎么老一脸嫌弃看我
Shure: Why do you always look at me with disdain?
Shure: 给你脑袋拧死
Shure: I'll twist your head off.
Shure: 嘎巴可以啊反正也是要换的
Shure: Crack! It's fine, it needs to be replaced anyway.
Shure: 哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 快把那天粉衣服那事换上哈哈哈
Shure: Quickly change into that pink outfit from that day, hahaha.
其他人：为什么
Other: Why?
Katrina: 要上楼吗
Katrina: Going upstairs?
Shure: 快把妹妹还我
Shure: Quickly give me my sister back.
Alice: 干什么you jump
Alice: What are you doing, you jump?
Alice: I jump了
Alice: I jumped.
Shure: 这么开放吗妈
Shure: So open-minded, mom?
Shure: 都允许找小的了
Shure: Now it's okay to look for younger ones?
其他人：嗯是呢
Other: Yeah, it is.
Lucia: 我是那个朱立文建材
Lucia: I'm from Zhuliwen Building Materials.
Shure: 对4个人都好这样是吧
Shure: Right, all four of us are like this, huh?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：突然有点不好搜
Other: It's suddenly a bit hard to search.
Shure: 还是不止4个妈妈
Shure: It's not just four moms.
Lucia: 就是这个名字
Lucia: That's the name.
Lucia: 他比较长就哈哈
Lucia: It's quite long, so haha.
Alice: 刘婷你愿意出多少钱买我的狗
Alice: Liu Ting, how much would you pay for my dog?
其他人：什么你让我花钱
Other: What? You want me to pay?
Alice: 哈哈哈我的狗不值钱吗
Alice: Hahaha, is my dog not worth anything?
Alice: 在外边呢
Alice: It's outside.
Alice: 你能把它迎接回来吗
Alice: Can you bring it back?
Alice: 待会再迎接吧
Alice: Let's bring it back later.
Alice: 你愿意出多少买它
Alice: How much are you willing to pay for it?
其他人：不要我的命哈哈哈
Other: Not my life, hahaha.
Shure: 你在干嘛
Shure: What are you doing?
其他人：你的心理价位是多少
Others: What's your psychological price?
Shure: 你在用网易
Shure: Are you using NetEase?
Shure: 网易云社交软件是吗
Shure: Is it NetEase social software?
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 上个座要么躺着
Shure: Either sit or lie down.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 原来这样
Shure: Oh, I see.
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Oh my.
Shure: 来呀过来玩啊哈哈哈
Shure: Come on, come over and play, hahaha.
Alice:你那你那房间装饰好了吗
Alice: Have you decorated your room yet?
Shure: 对不起忘了有人了
Shure: Sorry, I forgot someone was here.
Lucia: 就就就这样吧
Lucia: Just leave it like that.
Lucia: 管他呢反正是好了就
Lucia: Doesn't matter, as long as it's done.
Alice:就这样了
Alice: It's done.
其他人：没人就可以这样吗
Others: Can we do this if no one's here?
Lucia: 呵呵
Lucia: Hehe
Alice: 你见过我的完整版吗
Alice: Have you seen my complete version?
Lucia: 我可以看一下吗
Lucia: Can I take a look?
Alice: 啊你可以
Alice: Ah, sure.
Lucia: 我那个在大家去看之前
Lucia: Before everyone sees it.
Lucia: 我还再去粘一下
Lucia: I'll stick it again.
Lucia: 因为美纹纸特别容易掉
Lucia: Because the masking tape falls off easily.
Shure: 上去吧
Shure: Go on up.
其他人：你的不也掉了吗
Others: Didn't yours fall off too?
Alice: 我掉了还没粘上呢
Alice: Mine fell off and I haven't stuck it back yet.
Shure: 吃点啥喝点啥
Shure: Want something to eat or drink?
Lucia: 哦没事哈哈
Lucia: Oh, it's okay, haha.
Alice: 好的我去
Alice: Alright, I'll go.
Lucia: 好的那你去修整一下
Lucia: Alright, go fix it up.
Alice: 我去补救一下
Alice: I'll go patch it up.
Lucia: 我跟你一起去修整一下
Lucia: I'll go with you to fix it.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Shure: 有威士忌有朗姆有Tequila
Shure: We have whiskey, rum, tequila.
Lucia: 哇你的房间好香呀哎
Lucia: Wow, your room smells so nice.
其他人：突然突然突然开始说英文
Others: Suddenly speaking English.
其他人：我以为你能叫我猫
Others: I thought you could call me a cat.
Shure: 呵呵呵
Shure: Hehehe
Lucia: 可惜还没有过来
Lucia: Too bad it hasn't come over yet.
Shure: 对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Shure: 那我应该这样有威士忌
Shure: So I should have whiskey like this.
Shure: 龙蛇胆狼
Shure: Dragon snake gall wolf.
Alice: 这是巧克力豆
Alice: These are chocolate beans.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:比我命还硬
Alice: They're tougher than me.
Lucia: 哎呀我决定过会再再冲他
Lucia: Oh man, I decided to rinse it again later.
Tasha: 算了
Tasha: Forget it.
Lucia: 太头大了
Lucia: It's too overwhelming.
Alice: 哦 有一点碎的下面有
Alice: Oh, there's some broken pieces at the bottom.
Shure: 这是我们每天的生活
Shure: This is our daily life.
Alice: 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
其他人：我帮你把照片记
Others: I’ll help you remember the photos.
Alice: 你吃巧克力吗
Alice: Do you eat chocolate?
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure.
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
其他人：如果你想要你就去拿
Others: If you want it, go get it.
Tasha: 姐
Tasha: Sis.
其他人：哦我前两天我把他那个日期设置
Others: Oh, a couple of days ago, I set the date.
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's okay.
其他人：设置好了
Others: It’s set.
Shure: 就是洗脸水液
Shure: It's just face wash liquid.
Alice: 好吃吗
Alice: Is it good?
其他人：对他现在又冲洗出来是在日期头
Others: Yeah, it’s now rinsed out and is at the top of the date.
Alice: 好吃这个都给你吃
Alice: It's good, you can have it all.
Alice: 这个反正用不上
Alice: Anyway, we don’t need this.
Shure: 高级
Shure: Fancy.
Alice:给吧
Alice: Take it.
Shure: 小时候那个打出来的都带
Shure: When I was a kid, they all had it.
Alice: 公主请吃
Alice: Princess, please eat.
其他人：然后现在我们大概有
Others: And now we roughly have
其他人：五十几张照片
Others: About fifty photos.
Shure: 我们
Shure: We.
其他人：因为我带了一盒新的嘛
Others: Because I brought a new box.
其他人：然后那个啊好像拍到了20
Others: And then, ah, it seems to have taken 20.
Tasha: 然后这个就可以拿上去了
Tasha: Then this can be taken up.
Alice: 怎么了呢
Alice: What's wrong?
Tasha: 但是也可以最后在拿就是一起拿
Tasha: But it can also be taken last, just take it all together.
Tasha: 蛋塔还没烤还要半个小时就全部做完了
Tasha: The egg tarts are not baked yet, it will take another half an hour to finish everything.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Tasha: 这个冰一下的话会变硬
Tasha: If you freeze this, it will harden.
Shure: 这你化妆包是吗
Shure: Is this your makeup bag?
Tasha: 趁热吃
Tasha: Eat while it's hot.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 怎么改的呢
Shure: How did you change it?
Shure: 化成小袋的了
Shure: Turned it into small bags.
其他人：因为那个装起来不是很方便哦
Others: Because it's not very convenient to pack it that way.
其他人：所以你拿我充电线干嘛
Others: So why are you using my charging cable?
Shure: 这不准备日日给你放回去吗
Shure: I'm planning to put it back every day, right?
Tasha: 然后提拉米苏拿出来
Tasha: Then take out the tiramisu.
Shure: 急什么急什么
Shure: Why the rush? Why the rush?
Alice: 嗯咋了
Alice: Hmm, what's up?
其他人：你有一根头发
Others: You have a hair.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 我们的抹茶粉
Alice: Our matcha powder.
Jake: 要帮忙吗
Jake: Need any help?
Tasha: 衣服拿一下吧
Tasha: Can you take the clothes?
Shure: 他怎么开的来着
Shure: How did he open it?
其他人：取景器旁边有一个圆形的
Others: There's a round button next to the viewfinder.
Shure: 按住是吗
Shure: Press it, right?
Alice:恩
Alice: Yeah.
其他人：对你按一下看上面屏幕亮就可以了
Others: Yes, press it and see if the top screen lights up.
Shure: 它是没电了吗
Shure: Is it out of battery?
Shure: 它好像真没电了
Shure: It really seems out of battery.
Tasha: 这能都洗一下吗
Tasha: Can you wash all of these?
其他人：不能啊
Others: No, you can't.
其他人：我不会昨天忘记关了吧
Others: Did I forget to turn it off yesterday?
Alice: 不要偷吃刘婷
Alice: Don't steal food, Liu Ting.
Alice: 我指名点姓的提醒你
Alice: I'm specifically calling you out.
其他人：只能点名
Others: Only call out names.
其他人：污蔑我哈
Others: Slandering me, huh?
其他人：不会吧
Others: No way.
Alice: 不会吧
Alice: No way.
Shure: 这电池是什么样的
Shure: What kind of battery is this?
Alice: 你不会偷吃吧
Alice: You wouldn't steal food, right?
Shure: 是充电的吗
Shure: Is it rechargeable?
Shure: 还是电池
Shure: Or battery-powered?
其他人：不是一个特有专门的电池
Others: It's a special kind of battery.
Alice: 不是本人
Alice: It's not me.
Alice: 刚刚好像有什么东西上我身了
Alice: It felt like something just possessed me.
其他人：这是一个312的电池
Others: It's a 312 battery.
Alice: 哈哈哈退退
Alice: Hahaha, back off.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's okay.
Shure: 拿出来咬一口
Shure: Take it out and have a bite.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
其他人：我怎么老干这种事情
Others: Why do I always do this kind of stuff?
Shure: 其实我不意外哈
Shure: Actually, I'm not surprised.
其他人：能啊我怎么会忘记关机呢
Others: How could I forget to turn it off?
Shure: 谁知道了
Shure: Who knows?
其他人：我昨天用了吗昨天没用前天
Others: Did I use it yesterday? No, the day before yesterday.
Tasha: 没事没事别动
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay, don't move.
Shure: 拍哪个小哥哥忘关了啊
Shure: Who's that guy who forgot to turn it off?
其他人：我不会那天设置日期的时候忘掉了
Others: Maybe I forgot when I was setting the date.
Shure: 哦有可能
Shure: Oh, that’s possible.
Shure: 装作我拍一下
Shure: I'll pretend to take a shot.
其他人：这是我手机还是
Others: Is this my phone or...
Shure: 这是我的座凳
Shure: This is my seat.
Shure: AI记录一下
Shure: AI, make a note.
Shure: 人类拍照是这样拍的
Shure: This is how humans take pictures.
Shure: 咔嚓
Shure: Click.
其他人：塞包里不要放外面
Others: Put it in the bag, don’t leave it out.
Shure: 我给你塞包里了
Shure: I put it in your bag.
Alice: 你跟我在一块那么久
Alice: You've been with me for so long.
Shure: 还还怎么塞
Shure: How, how do I put it in?
Alice: 你你不找我
Alice: And you didn't look for me.
Alice: 手机壳啥样
Alice: What does the phone case look like?
Shure: 看着点再坐
Shure: Watch where you're sitting.
Tasha: 嗯湿的不行
Tasha: Uh, it's too wet.
Shure: 带的非常全
Shure: Everything is fully prepared.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
其他人：好生气啊
Others: So angry.
Shure: 别哭别哭
Shure: Don't cry, don't cry.
Shure: 别哭别哭别哭哈哈哈
Shure: Don't cry, don't cry, don't cry, hahaha.
其他人：嗯别蹭我
Others: Uh, don't rub against me.
Alice: 要不你去找我那挂纸给贴上
Alice: How about you get my poster and stick it up?
Shure: 嫌弃我感情淡了
Shure: You think our relationship has faded.
Tasha: 啊先不着急处那个你能拿
Tasha: Ah, don't rush that, can you get...
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Alice: 咱俩这关系
Alice: The relationship between us...
Alice: 如果提钱
Alice: If we talk about money...
其他人：哦今天成都草莓
Others: Oh, today is Chengdu Strawberry.
Alice: 我那狗不值200吗
Alice: My dog isn't worth 200?
其他人：我的劳动不值200吗
Others: Is my labor not worth 200?
Alice: 我就跟你说人民币我还没说刀呢真是我还没
Alice: I told you in RMB, I haven't even mentioned dollars yet, seriously, I haven't
Shure: 我用哪个服务器欠费
Shure: Which server am I using that's overdue?
Alice: 我还没给你算别的品种呢
Alice: I haven't even accounted for other breeds yet
Shure: 哎
Shure: Sigh
Alice: 我给你算人民币你还闲我黑
Alice: I'm quoting you in RMB and you still think I'm ripping you off
Shure: 这给毕设花多少钱
Shure: How much did this graduation project cost?
其他人：可以报的呀
Others: It can be reimbursed!
Shure: 学校那个报销报的
Shure: The school can reimburse it
Shure: 我的妈呀
Shure: Oh my gosh
Shure: 我都毕业了
Shure: I've already graduated
Shure: 那卡估计都给我停了
Shure: The card is probably deactivated by now
其他人：以后一定要记得带备用电池
Others: From now on, always remember to bring spare batteries
其他人：哦我单反的电我也得记得 充
Others: Oh, I also need to remember to charge my DSLR battery
其他人：所以下周我出门我要不要带相机
Others: So, should I bring my camera next week?
Shure: 单反吗
Shure: A DSLR?
Shure:  那他可要走一大圈
Shure: It would mean carrying a lot
其他人：那到无所谓感觉设备是不是会有点沉
Others: That doesn't matter, but won't the equipment be heavy?
其他人：我只带照片的话越高
Others: If I'm just carrying photos, the higher the better
其他人：但我还是感觉对拍照单反
Others: But I still think for taking photos, a DSLR is better
其他人：相机拍的是手机像素
Others: The camera's quality is like a phone's pixels
Jake: 对对对 算了算了算了算了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, forget it, forget it
Shure: 可以
Shure: Fine
其他人：那如果说要拍照的话
Others: So if we want to take pictures
Alice: 真嘟假嘟
Alice: Really?
其他人：迪士尼好像有乐拍通然后其他地方拍
Others: Disney seems to have a photo service, and other places too
Alice: 你知道怎么挂吗
Alice: Do you know how to hang it?
Alice: 那你就这么自信的走过去
Alice: Then confidently walk over
Alice: 你再给我装饰
Alice: And decorate it for me
Alice: 破坏了 美景破坏了
Alice: It's ruining the scenery, ruining it
其他人：我就逛展的话应该也需要带
Others: If I'm just visiting an exhibition, I should bring it
Shure: 你带着吧
Shure: You should bring it
其他人：所以我能不能给你几件衣服你帮我装着我只有一个小箱子
Others: So can I give you a few clothes to carry for me? I only have a small suitcase
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello
Shure: hello
Shure: Hello
Jake:哈喽
Jake: Hello
Shure: 杨老板你好
Shure: Hi Jake
Jake:你好
Jake: Hi
Shure: 你得穿衣服吗姐
Shure: Do you need to wear clothes, sis?
Shure: 哈哈哈什么叫飞飞
Shure: Hahaha, what do you mean by "flying"?
其他人：什么东西
Others: What is that?
Shure: 什么话这叫
Shure: What kind of talk is that?
其他人：你什么话呀
Others: What are you talking about?
Shure: 非穿不可的衣服
Shure: Clothes you definitely have to wear.
其他人：就是因为感觉好像就是大家如果说去迪士尼穿那种特别可爱的衣服
Others: Just because it feels like if you go to Disney, you need to wear those really cute outfits.
其他人：但是我没有
Others: But I don't have any.
Shure: 买
Shure: Buy them.
Shure: 穿个牛纳佩耳机你觉得我会有吗
Shure: Wearing a pair of Shure's GFnape headphones, do you think I would have any?
Shure: 你穿我那骷髅屁
Shure: You wear my skull...
其他人：它那个会热
Others: That would be hot.
Shure: 也是
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 还有穿小裙子
Shure: And also wear a little dress.
Shure: 我好像真的有一个粉色的
Shure: I think I really have a pink one.
Shure: 应该这么长一个裙子
Shure: It should be about this long.
Shure: 不是那个背带裙
Shure: Not the pinafore dress.
Shure: 因为背带裙我觉得很甜因为有一点太
Shure: Because I think the pinafore dress is very sweet but a bit too...
Shure: 热
Shure: Hot.
其他人：就是你把它折起来它会有一个很大的
Others: If you fold it, it will have a big...
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Ah, okay.
其他人：可以穿这样的
Others: You can wear it like this.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
其他人：可换电池我那个是一次性的
Others: It has replaceable batteries, mine is disposable.
Shure: 看不到看不到电池哦
Shure: Can't see, can't see the batteries, oh.
其他人：电池
Others: Batteries.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 饿了
Shure: Hungry.
Shure: 带你觅食走
Shure: I'll take you to find food.
其他人：等会的
Others: Wait a moment.
Shure: 躺会吧
Shure: Let's lie down for a bit.
其他人：你翻过来我没地方靠
Others: Turn over, I have no place to lean on.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
其他人：我在看个手表
Others: I'm looking at a watch.
Shure: CR123A
Shure: CR123A.
Shure: （歌词）我到底做了什么让你难过
Shure: (Lyrics) What did I do to make you sad?
Shure: 我应该
Shure: I should...
Alice: 香 没事
Alice: Fragrant, it's okay.
其他人：我不知道胶片机能不能用可充电因
Others: I don't know if the film camera can use rechargeable batteries.
Shure: 为电压有问题吗
Shure: Is there a problem with the voltage?
其他人：不是因为设计的就是
Others: No, it's just the design.
其他人：所以不一定能用
Others: So it might not work.
Alice: 无妨好吃就行
Alice: Never mind, as long as it tastes good.
Tasha: 恩
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:不可以吃
Alice: You can't eat it.
Tasha: 豆呢刚才的豆呢
Tasha: What about the beans, the beans from earlier?
Alice: 洗了吗洗了吗
Alice: Did you wash them, did you wash them?
Alice:这个洗过就可以吃
Alice: If you wash them, you can eat them.
Tasha: 豆
Tasha: Beans.
Alice: 巧克力豆嘛
Alice: Chocolate beans, right?
Shure: 我应该帮忙去
Shure: I should help.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is it?
Shure: 看型号
Shure: Look at the model.
Alice: 你想给我们捐点吗
Alice: Do you want to donate to us?
Shure: CR2
Shure: CR2.
Alice: 你来报销
Alice: You reimburse it.
Shure: 他只要是叫这个名
Shure: As long as it's called that name.
Shure: 型号的应该都是一样啊
Shure: Models should all be the same, right?
Alice: 这话是可以说的吗
Alice: Can you even say that?
其他人：你非得给他拿起来
Others: You just have to pick it up.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 你为啥
Alice: Why?
Shure: 但是01-2026和你这01-2034有什么区别吗
Shure: But what's the difference between 01-2026 and your 01-2034?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 鲜
Alice: Fresh.
Tasha: 比较有要求的女生
Tasha: More demanding girl.
Shure: 原来是保质期
Shure: So it was about the expiration date.
Alice:那必须
Alice: Of course.
Alice:像像
Alice: Looks like it.
Alice: 你别再发出那种魔性的声音了
Alice: Stop making that weird sound.
Alice:好吗
Alice: Okay?
Alice: 我跟你说啊
Alice: I'm telling you.
Alice: 你万一发生了像那天的事
Alice: If something like that happens again.
Alice: 我跟你说你
Alice: I'm telling you,
Alice: 今年你就得内向了你知道吗
Alice: you'll have to be introverted this year, you know?
其他人：希望在我出发之前它能到
Others: I hope it arrives before I leave.
Alice: 一次
Alice: Once.
Shure: 不 到我给你背着
Shure: No, I'll carry it for you.
Tasha: 好够了够了
Tasha: Alright, that's enough, enough.
Alice: 你有哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: You've got hahaha
其他人：那我这个就有一段时间没法用啊
Others: Then I won't be able to use this for a while.
其他人：但我那还有几个一次性的
Others: But I still have a few disposable ones.
Alice: 会重蹈覆辙的我跟你说
Alice: You'll make the same mistake again, I'm telling you.
Alice: 我只能这么告诉你
Alice: That's all I can tell you.
Shure: 眯眯眼
Shure: Squinty eyes.
Alice:呖哈哈哈怎么不唱了哈哈哈
Alice: Why did you stop singing? Haha.
Alice: 怎么不唱了
Alice: Why did you stop singing?
其他人：真讨厌
Others: So annoying.
Alice: 你想进去啊
Alice: Do you want to go in?
其他人：这是什么
Others: What's this?
其他人：嗯这个轮子好看
Others: Hmm, this wheel looks nice.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：你真讨厌
Others: You're so annoying.
其他人：我这已经全都是
Others: It's all over me now.
其他人：胶片胶片胶片胶片胶片胶片
Others: Film, film, film, film, film, film.
其他人：这是什么好可爱
Others: What's this? So cute.
Alice: 你现在怎么变内向了
Alice: Why have you become so introverted now?
Alice: 刘婷你不是挺爱说话的吗
Alice: Liu Ting, didn't you used to be talkative?
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh man.
Jake:我去
Shure: 太棒了
Shure: Awesome.
Jake: 这个留着让大伙一起挤
Jake: Let's save this and squeeze it all together.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 怎么这么摇滚上来
Shure: Why does it sound so rock?
Shure: 这还是那什么吗
Shure: Is this still the same thing?
Shure: 喝口吗
Shure: Want a sip?
其他人：什么
Others: What?
Shure: 威士忌
Shure: Whiskey.
其他人：怎么这个颜色
Others: Why is it this color?
其他人：放了多少苏打水
Others: How much soda did you add?
Shure: 不知道
Shure: No idea.
Shure: 哎那瓶朗姆
Shure: Hey, that bottle of rum.
Shure: 不是那瓶龙舌兰去哪了
Shure: No, where did that bottle of tequila go?
其他人：一点酒味都没有
Others: It doesn't taste like alcohol at all.
Katrina: 啥时候开始啊
Katrina: When are we starting?
Shure: 我们什么时候开始
Shure: When are we starting?
Katrina: 催一下
Katrina: Hurry them up.
Katrina: 他们那甜点没做好
Katrina: Their dessert isn't ready yet.
Shure: 你们在干嘛哦
Shure: What are you guys doing?
其他人：一会我马上坐上Eagle boss变身成Eagle
Others: In a bit, I'll sit on the Eagle boss and transform into an Eagle.
其他人：nice好像湿了
Others: Nice, seems like it's wet.
Shure: 咦什么咦
Shure: Huh? What do you mean "huh"?
其他人：下去晒太阳
Others: Go down and sunbathe.
Shure: 走走晒太阳去
Shure: Let's go, let's go sunbathe.
其他人：没有太阳会缺钙的
Others: Without sunlight, we'll lack calcium.
其他人：好这给你搞成一个了
Others: Here, I made one for you.
其他人：缺钙有know
Others: Lacking calcium, you know.
Shure: yeah i know
Shure: Yeah, I know.
Shure: like a guy
Shure: Like a guy.
Shure: 因为钙我忘了怎么说了
Shure: Because of calcium, I forgot how to say it.
Shure: 那么下一
Shure: So next...
Shure: 周太阳没了啊
Shure: The sun will be gone next week.
Shure: 有
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:啊 跟姐妹待这长时间
Alice: Ah, spending so much time with my girlfriends.
Shure: 我以为太阳没了
Shure: I thought the sun was gone.
其他人：什么太阳没了
Others: What do you mean the sun is gone?
Shure: 杨老板你好
Shure: Hi Jake.
Jake: 你好
Jake: Hi.
Jake: 你来指导一下
Jake: Can you give some guidance?
Jake: 买点啥今天我们吃的那个东西
Jake: What should we buy for what we're eating today?
Shure: 谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss.
其他人：现在就买啊
Others: Buy it now?
Jake: 没有没有就准备好就行 下个单
Jake: No, no, just get it ready. Place the order.
Shure: 我们要买什么呢
Shure: What should we buy?
Jake: 下个单到时候一见
Jake: Place the order and we'll see.
Shure: 你搜搜有没有战点披萨
Shure: Can you search for battle pizza?
其他人：有没有那种外
Others: Is there that kind...
其他人：有没有那种平时买的
Others: The kind you usually buy.
其他人：就是什么超市里买的
Others: Like the ones from the supermarket.
Shure: 超市要买的
Shure: The ones you buy from the supermarket.
Shure: 咱没什么要买的
Shure: We don't have anything to buy.
Shure: 找一个阳光最足的地方是吗
Shure: Find the sunniest spot, right?
Shure: 进行一些光合作用
Shure: To do some photosynthesis.
Shure: 哎呦呦
Shure: Oh my.
Shure: 慢点您
Shure: Slow down.
其他人：站点
Others: A station.
Shure: 沾点搜搜没有
Shure: Didn't find anything on Soso.
Shure: 这草还真有
Shure: This grass is really here.
其他人：到店
Others: To the store.
Shure: 但是到店不行
Shure: But going to the store doesn't work.
Shure: 那什么还是跑腿
Shure: So it's still delivery.
Shure: 不是主要只有站点有那个
Shure: No, only the station has that.
Shure: 就是32寸那种披萨你知道吧
Shure: You know, like the 32-inch pizza.
Shure: 然后点好那个站点对
Shure: Then order it from the station, right.
其他人：我能不能直接上美团跑腿买站点披萨
Others: Can I just use Meituan to get the station pizza?
Shure: 要先点好
Shure: You have to order first.
其他人：咋点了
Others: How to order?
Shure: 好问题
Shure: Good question.
Shure: 搜小程序呢
Shure: Search for the mini program.
Lucia: 夏紫檀我同学说是这个院子吗
Lucia: Xia Zitan, my classmate said it's this yard, right?
Lucia: 啊他应该到了吧
Lucia: Ah, he should be here by now.
其他人：啊我去接吧
Others: Ah, I'll go pick him up.
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 我是不是应该换个鞋
Lucia: Should I change my shoes?
Lucia: 算了先不换了
Lucia: Never mind, I'll leave them.
Jake: yes
Jake: Yes.
Jake: Lucia是去接了吗
Jake: Did Lucia go to pick him up?
其他人：在那个时光旅人5号院那边
Others: Over at Traveler's Time No. 5 Yard.
Jake: 是的哦那很好啊
Jake: Yes, that's great.
Lucia: 对在哪来着你你在
Lucia: Yeah, where was it again? Are you at...
Jake: 对就接55
Jake: Yeah, just pick him up and it's fine.
Jake: 就接一下就到就好了
Jake: Just pick him up and it's all good.
Jake: 让他们坐好吧要不
Jake: Have them sit down, maybe.
Shure: 你先退一下再进就好了
Shure: Just log out and back in, and it's fine.
Jake: 对 坐到二楼坐好
Jake: Yes, sit on the second floor.
Lucia: 是长这样吗
Lucia: Does it look like this?
Lucia: 他虽然还在转
Lucia: It's still spinning though.
Jake:恩  这儿了这儿了
Jake: Yeah, it's here, it's here.
Shure: 感谢你特别邀请来见证
Shure: Thanks for the special invitation to witness this.
其他人：卧槽太慢了
Others: Damn, it's so slow.
Shure: 什么手机啊换了吧
Shure: What phone is this? Change it.
其他人：天天天天在这里让人家换手机
Others: Every day, every day here, asking people to change their phones.
Shure: 你再往这边走一点点对好
Shure: Move a bit this way, yeah, perfect.
Shure: 正好挡脸上了
Shure: Right in front of your face now.
其他人：老板说上二楼坐好
Others: Boss said sit on the second floor.
Shure: 徐老师那个卡带马说给你寄回去
Shure: Mr. Xu, Ma said he'll send the tape back to you.
Shure: 他说一玩就停不下来了
Shure: He said once he starts playing, he can't stop.
Shure: 不能再玩了
Shure: He can't play anymore.
Shure: 影响你俩幸福了是吗
Shure: Is it affecting your happiness?
Katrina: 受不了了
Katrina: Can't take it anymore.
Katrina: 赶紧上去
Katrina: Hurry up.
其他人：这这几个东西
Others: These things...
Katrina: 特别欠你看
Katrina: Really annoying, look.
Shure: 我的锅
Shure: My bad.
其他人：全是柳絮
Others: All catkins.
Katrina: 上
Katrina: Go.
其他人：点个外卖
Others: Order some takeout.
Katrina: 点什么外卖
Katrina: What takeout?
Shure: 有有外卖是吗站点
Shure: Is there takeout available at the station?
Katrina: 不是晚饭吃披萨吗
Katrina: Aren't we having pizza for dinner?
其他人：上去了你还不走人家急的都走了
Others: You've gone up, but they're still waiting.
其他人：勾人
Others: So tempting.
其他人：那我就他妈现在搞了有啥用啊
Others: What's the use of doing it now?
Shure: 男的问你俩现在在干嘛
Shure: The guy is asking what you two are doing.
其他人：不是我不是想问他们俩哎呀
Others: No, I didn't mean to ask them, geez.
Shure: 你想问啥
Shure: What do you want to ask?
其他人：我想问为什么突然开始OK
Others: I want to ask why it started suddenly, OK?
其他人：我在问你
Others: I'm asking you.
其他人：我不在问你
Others: Not asking you.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Shure: 哎呀那你说他俩在干嘛
Shure: Well, then what are they doing?
Shure: 那你说你俩在干嘛
Shure: What are you two doing?
其他人：哈哈在干嘛呀
Others: Haha, what are you doing?
Shure: 主语错了主语错了主语错了
Shure: The subject is wrong, the subject is wrong, the subject is wrong.
其他人：哇你现在跟我说这个东西
Others: Wow, you're telling me this now?
其他人：好像啊
Others: Seems like it.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 饿了吧
Shure: Hungry, right?
Shure: 确实他会腱鞘炎的
Shure: Seriously, he might get tenosynovitis.
Shure: 我那段玩也是
Shure: I got it from playing too.
Katrina: 这是他们的货币
Katrina: This is their currency.
Katrina: 拿着不
Katrina: Want to take it?
其他人：拿着
Others: Take it.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice: 那刘婷顾头不顾腚
Alice: Liu Ting only cares about the head, not the rear end.
Alice: 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting
其他人：没关系你幸不幸福不知道反正姐妹现在在幸福
Others: It doesn't matter if you're happy, as long as your sister is happy now.
Alice: 哦 你给他拿上去顺便骂他一下
Alice: Oh, take it to him and scold him while you're at it.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈真贱这俩人
Shure: Hahaha, these two are such jerks.
Alice: 说她顾头不顾腚
Alice: Tell her she's focusing on one thing and ignoring the other.
其他人：怎么了吗
Others: What's wrong?
Alice: 这个小不小
Alice: Is this small or not?
Shure: 告诉AI不能这样子
Shure: Tell AI it can't be like this.
Tasha: 这个我我我想要更小一点
Tasha: This... I want it a bit smaller.
Tasha: 就是这这个边的哦嗯
Tasha: Like this edge here, oh hmm.
Alice: 就是这个边的
Alice: Like this edge.
Alice: 好满足
Alice: So satisfying.
Shure: 太饿了
Shure: So hungry.
Shure: 赶紧滚哈
Shure: Hurry up and get out of here.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 走上去
Shure: Go upstairs.
其他人：我需要把我的那几个胶片带着吗上去
Others: Do I need to bring my films upstairs?
Shure: 他不没电了吗
Shure: Isn't it out of battery?
其他人：啊那个钥匙扣啊
Others: Ah, that keychain.
Katrina: 上楼吧速速开始
Katrina: Let's go upstairs, start quickly.
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 迟到43分钟哈哈哈
Katrina: 43 minutes late, hahaha.
Shure: 现在也可以
Shure: Now's fine too.
Shure: 你先穿上吧
Shure: You put it on first.
Shure: 我给你穿上
Shure: I'll help you put it on.
Lucia: 我刚刚那个充电宝的线上哪去了
Lucia: Where did the charging cable for my power bank go?
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a sec.
Shure: 到时候伺机而动见机行事
Shure: Just be opportunistic when the time comes.
Lucia: 这是我的线吗
Lucia: Is this my cable?
Lucia: 哦这是我的线
Lucia: Oh, this is my cable.
其他人：什么什么见机行事
Others: What do you mean by opportunistic?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 全全allin是吗
Shure: Going all in, right?
其他人：反正没有人就无所谓
Others: Anyway, nobody cares if no one's around.
其他人：你怎么看不到的
Others: How come you can't see it?
Shure: 哦我靠这个是楼
Shure: Oh my, this is a building.
其他人：那是唯一一张的楼其他的都是海个地方的海
Others: That's the only picture of a building, the rest are all of the sea, different places of the sea.
Shure: 哦我靠太酷了
Shure: Oh my, that's so cool.
Shure: 这个就像那种草东专辑封面的感觉
Shure: This feels like the cover of a Grassland East album.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know, right?
其他人：他是一个黑白的
Others: He's a black and white one.
Shure: 对黑白
Shure: Yeah, black and white.
Shure: 他加上那种白色的线条
Shure: Plus those white lines.
Shure: 就跟那个丑努尔那个特别像
Shure: Just like that Chou Nur one, very similar.
Shure: 走上去
Shure: Go on.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Shure: 让AI看看
Shure: Let AI take a look.
Shure: 让害羞的人类是吗
Shure: Let the shy human, right?
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh no.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 给我吓到了
Shure: That scared me.
Jake: 请进
Jake: Come in.
Jake: 欢迎
Jake: Welcome.
Jake: 欢迎啊呵呵呵
Jake: Welcome, haha.
其他人：一会给你喊个麦
Others: We'll call you to the mic later.
其他人：你要不要重新来一遍
Others: Do you want to do it again?
Shure: 不必不必
Shure: No need, no need.
Shure: 公子马斯特
Shure: Master Gongzi.
Shure: 少爷嘛
Shure: Young Master.
Shure: 满三好你看
Shure: Look, it's all good.
Shure: 找找地儿坐
Shure: Find a place to sit.
Shure: 请坐请坐
Shure: Please sit, please sit.
Shure: 要不你坐我旁边
Shure: Why don't you sit next to me?
Shure: 就坐那个
Shure: Just sit there.
Shure: 席地而坐
Shure: Sit on the floor.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 把MC的位置让回给我
Shure: Give me back the MC spot.
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hey.
Shure: ladies and gentlemen
Shure: Ladies and gentlemen.
Lucia: 哈哈你俩可以坐一块
Lucia: Haha, you two can sit together.
Shure: 你突然不想跟我坐一块是吗哈哈
Shure: You suddenly don't want to sit with me, huh? Haha.
Lucia: 反正我一会应该还要下去弄那个甜点
Lucia: Anyway, I might need to go down to get the dessert later.
Shure: 给我来个宝呗
Shure: Bring me a charger.
Shure: 充电宝
Shure: Power bank.
Katrina: 哦哦哦sorry
Katrina: Oh oh oh, sorry.
Katrina: 一点默契都没有
Katrina: No coordination at all.
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
其他人：靖康拿个充电宝上来
Others: Jingkang, bring a power bank up.
Shure: 那那个那
Shure: That one, that...
Shure: 不是那是给
Shure: No, that's for
Shure: 给那个空间
Shure: for that space
Shure: 你怎么能直呼老板大名呢
Shure: How can you call the boss by his first name?
其他人：靖康有英文名吗没有
Others: Does Jingkang have an English name? No.
Shure: 他叫JK yes
Shure: He's called JK, yes.
Lucia: 好洋气哦
Lucia: So fancy.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 下下一秒就感觉又
Shure: Next second, it feels like
Lucia: 哦你今天还带了相机
Lucia: Oh, you brought a camera today.
Jake: 什么充电宝
Jake: What, a power bank?
Lucia: 久违的久违的相机哈哈
Lucia: The long-lost camera, haha.
Jake:那就拿点呗
Jake: Then just take some.
Katrina: 哦我也需要充电宝
Katrina: Oh, I need a power bank too.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 需要我做什么
Alice: Do you need me to do anything?
Katrina: 让我现
Katrina: Let me see
Lucia: 我以为你是在南京工作
Lucia: I thought you worked in Nanjing.
Lucia: 所以你是在北京工作
Lucia: So you work in Beijing?
Lucia: 你有啊老乡
Lucia: You have, ah, a fellow townsperson.
Katrina: 我现
Katrina: I see.
Lucia: 你在南京工作的呀
Lucia: You worked in Nanjing.
Shure: 这是保温杯
Shure: This is a thermos.
Lucia: 哎我怎
Lucia: Hey, I
Lucia: 那我可能是某一次刷到你定位在南京
Lucia: Maybe I once saw your location in Nanjing.
Katrina: 思考
Katrina: Thinking.
Lucia: 还是怎么回事
Lucia: Or something.
Lucia: 嗯OK OK
Lucia: Hmm, OK, OK.
Lucia: 我现在在
Lucia: I'm now at
Lucia: 我还在我家那
Lucia: I'm still at my home
Lucia: 边主要我今年下半年可能还在出国去
Lucia: Besides, I might go abroad in the second half of this year.
Shure: 我们要开始吗
Shure: Shall we start?
其他人：you are now let's welcome today's presenter
Others: you are now let's welcome today's presenter
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: ok
Shure: OK.
Shure: 等等拿完包的
Shure: Wait, after taking the bag.
Lucia: presenter是谁啊
Lucia: Who is the presenter?
Lucia: 森达
Lucia: Senda.
其他人：杨靖康
Others: Jake Jingkang.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
其他人：感觉没开
Others: Feels like it's not on.
Lucia: 你带的那个吗
Lucia: Did you bring that?
其他人：啊你带的那没事
Others: Ah, you brought that, it's fine.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我
Lucia: Hahaha, I...
Lucia: 我要不我下楼给你拿一瓶咱的
Lucia: How about I go downstairs and get you a bottle of ours?
Lucia: 你要喝啥
Lucia: What do you want to drink?
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Shure: 自带酒水了是吗
Shure: You brought your own drinks?
Lucia: 你喝吗他可不喝哈哈哈
Lucia: Do you want to drink? He doesn't drink, hahaha.
Lucia: 没事人家还没打开呢
Lucia: It's fine, it hasn't been opened yet.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 看我们的充电线
Katrina: Look at our charging cable.
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 因为我们前几天刚好买的是同款茶
Lucia: Because we just happened to buy the same tea a few days ago.
Lucia: 然后对大家以为还有给你先放到这
Lucia: So everyone thought there was still some left, and they put it here for you first.
其他人：坐在最前面像个傻缺一样
Others: Sitting in the front like a fool.
Shure: 没有不
Shure: No, not at all.
Shure: 一点不像
Shure: Not at all.
Lucia: 啥这个上面吗
Lucia: What, this one on top?
其他人：egohorse
Others: egohorse.
Shure: 对他是一个nice
Shure: Yeah, he's a nice one.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 所以我们
Jake: So we...
Jake: let's
Jake: let's...
Katrina: 谁是主持人啊
Katrina: Who's the host?
Katrina: 你啊
Katrina: You are.
Jake: 因为下面的甜点还在准备
Jake: Because the desserts are still being prepared.
Jake: 所以还有点奶油要挤
Jake: So there's still some cream to be added.
Lucia: 需要我去celebrate一下吗嗯
Lucia: Do you need me to celebrate a bit?
Jake: 我们就开始4点吧
Jake: We'll start at 4 o'clock.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake: 就这么4点吧
Jake: Let's start at 4 o'clock then.
Jake: 好 4点开始
Jake: Alright, start at 4.
Katrina: 我们原定的3点开始
Katrina: We originally planned to start at 3.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 那你们开个场吧
Jake: Then you guys start.
Shure: 五十
Shure: Fifty.
Jake: 你要不就
Jake: How about you...
Jake: 你的music开场了
Jake: Your music to start.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
其他人：普通朋友应该是普通朋友
Other people: Ordinary friends should just be ordinary friends.
Shure: 不不不
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 给大家给大家放放点歌吧好吧
Shure: Let me play some songs for everyone, alright?
其他人：不行你唱
Other people: No, you sing.
Shure: 听我唱听我唱什么听我唱
Shure: Listen to me sing, listen to me sing what?
Shure: 给大家放放点
Shure: Let me play some songs.
Shure: 大家平时喜欢听什么呀
Shure: What do you all usually like to listen to?
其他人：普通朋友
Other people: Ordinary Friends.
Shure: 下一位嘉宾先来什么可以
Shure: Next guest, what would you like to hear?
Katrina: 哈哈哈他也听普通朋友的
Katrina: Hahaha, he also listens to Ordinary Friends.
Katrina: 两票普通朋友呢
Katrina: Two votes for Ordinary Friends.
Shure: 啊那后面那位哥哥
Shure: Ah, the guy in the back.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
其他人：普通朋友三票
Other people: Three votes for Ordinary Friends.
Shure: 两两两位同学
Shure: Two, two, two classmates.
其他人：普通朋友三票
Other people: Three votes for Ordinary Friends.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 放吧放别问了
Katrina: Just play it, stop asking.
Shure: 下面这首歌曲是所有嘉宾点的
Shure: The next song is requested by all the guests.
Shure: 普通朋友
Shure: Ordinary Friends.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Shure: 我应该对口型
Shure: I should lip-sync.
Shure: 那你看原唱懂吗
Shure: Then watch the original singer, you get it?
Shure: 我在
Shure: I'm here.
Shure: 这是苏拉水苏拉水
Shure: This is Sula water, Sula water.
其他人：一点酒味都没有
Other people: It doesn't taste like alcohol at all.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Shure: （歌词）我无法直视扑
Shure: (Lyrics) I can't look directly at...
Shure: 看
Shure: Look.
Shure: 看你
Shure: Look at you.
Shure: 喝点什么吗
Shure: Want to drink something?
Shure: white beer是吗
Shure: White beer, right?
Shure: 啊be
Shure: Ah, be...
Shure: 啊哈
Shure: Ah, ha.
Shure: 哦对
Shure: Oh, right.
Jake: 暖起来
Jake: Warm it up.
Shure: 好的好的
Shure: Okay, okay.
Jake: 专业暖场
Jake: Professional warm-up.
Shure: 是不是大家这个厂子不够不够
Shure: Isn't it that everyone's not enough, not enough...
Shure: 不够热那要不把空调调高两度吧
Shure: It's not warm enough, how about we turn up the air conditioner by two degrees?
Shure: 那个大家大家口渴什么的
Shure: If anyone is thirsty or anything,
Shure: 冰箱里有
Shure: there's stuff in the fridge.
Shure: 有橙汁桃汁
Shure: There's orange juice and peach juice,
Shure: 还有元气森林ad钙奶
Shure: also Genki Forest AD calcium milk.
Shure: 还有酒还有咖啡
Shure: There's also alcohol and coffee.
Katrina: 买的养乐多呢
Katrina: What about the Yakult we bought?
Shure: 大家想喝什么
Shure: What does everyone want to drink?
Katrina: 你有啥想喝的吗
Katrina: Do you want anything to drink?
Shure: 可以在我这里order一下点一下
Shure: You can order anything from me.
Shure: 这就不用好了
Shure: Actually, no need.
Shure: （歌词）我无法只是普通朋友
Shure: (Lyrics) I can't just be an ordinary friend.
Shure: 大家知道今天是什么日子吗
Shure: Does everyone know what day it is today?
其他人：4月21日
Others: April 21st.
Shure: 大家知道
Shure: Does everyone know
Shure: 今天自己参加这个活动的主题
Shure: the theme of today's event?
Shure: 叫什么吗
Shure: What's it called?
Shure: yes today is
Shure: Yes, today is
Shure: earth day
Shure: Earth Day.
Shure: 大家知道世界地球日是大概干什么
Shure: Do you know what Earth Day is about?
Shure: 的一个日子吗
Shure: What kind of day it is?
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Right?
Shure: 大家知道大概是干什么
Shure: Does anyone know what it's about?
Shure: 有没有踊跃举手回答的
Shure: Anyone wants to raise their hand and answer?
Shure: 就是我们有小红花作为奖励的
Shure: We have little red flowers as rewards.
Shure: 怎么了怎么了
Shure: What's up, what's up?
Shure: 下一首放什么呀大家
Shure: What's the next song, everyone?
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 瞎说
Shure: Nonsense.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 再问你一遍
Shure: I'll ask you again,
Shure: 你喜欢听什么哈哈哈
Shure: What kind of music do you like? Haha.
其他人：流沙
Others: Quicksand.
其他人：版本哪个版本哈
Others: Which version, haha.
Shure: 我送你两个字沙雕
Shure: I'll give you two words: sand sculpture.
其他人：爱情好像流沙
Others: Love is like quicksand.
Katrina: 我不敢
Katrina: I don't dare.
Katrina: 我的转移要破的
Katrina: My transfer is going to break.
Shure: 给大家
Shure: For everyone.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh.
Shure: 对咱们4点开始
Shure: Yes, let's start at 4.
Shure: 还有
Shure: Also,
Shure: 5分钟
Shure: 5 minutes.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 给大家先放一点
Shure: Let's play a little something
Shure: 这个跟今天日子相关的这种
Shure: related to today's date.
Shure: 来自迈克尔杰克逊的Heal the world
Shure: From Michael Jackson, "Heal the World".
Shure: 你干嘛
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 好久没见乐子了是吗
Shure: Haven't seen anything fun in a while, huh?
其他人：最近活的是挺无聊也不无聊最近看了不少乐子
Others: Recently, life's been boring but not boring, been seeing some fun stuff.
Shure: 好什么乐子
Shure: What fun stuff?
其他人：大家都很乐
Others: Everyone's been having fun.
Shure: 逛展
Shure: Going to exhibitions.
其他人：逛什么展
Others: What exhibitions?
其他人：啊那个不算了那个不算了
Others: Ah, that doesn't count, that doesn't count.
Shure: 这个东西会不会当钱
Shure: Can this thing be used as money?
Shure: 谢宾主
Shure: Thank the host.
其他人：我靠我靠厉害
Others: Wow, wow, impressive.
Shure: 咖啡没上劲是吗
Shure: The coffee didn't kick in, right?
Shure: 假的是吗
Shure: It's fake, right?
其他人：就是脑子已经醒了别的还没醒
Others: My brain's awake but the rest isn't.
Shure: 怎么醒怎么能醒
Shure: How to wake up? How can we wake up?
其他人：怎么都醒不了
Others: Can't wake up no matter what.
其他人：你不要乱动
Others: Don't move around.
Shure: （歌词）there are people dying
Shure: (Lyrics) There are people dying.
其他人：冲那个充学校
Others: Charge that, charge the school.
其他人：你可以使点劲
Others: You can put some effort into it.
Shure: 使点劲就喊疼
Shure: Put some effort and they'll shout in pain.